Advanced comedy ghosts uh surprise
return of a major character one of my
favorite shows fans may remember the
Headless ghost from the 19th his name
was crash yeah the pilot the very first
episode and then he mysteriously
disappeared in this week's episode
there's an investigation to find out who
hit crash's head in the woods for a year
here's a little preview
where were you on the night of the
incident
here in the mansion that I'm stuck in
for all of eternity care to be more
specific tough guy do you have an alibi
I don't remember it was a year ago do
you guys remember what you were doing a
year ago very interesting no alibi I am
not responsible which I would think
would be obvious what do you mean by
them if I wanted to dispose of Crash his
head I certainly wouldn't have tossed it
into the woods no
I would have waited for a moonless night
and dropped it into the inky Waters of
the old world on the other side of the
property
[Music]
if I had done it no one would have ever
found him
[Music]
Rebecca wasaki plays the Gilded Age
socialite heady on the show and Brandon
Scott Jones is the Revolutionary War
soldier Isaac and they both join us yes
yes thank you gosh I love it uh so you
know I was Trevor for Halloween yeah
another character we're very jealous my
wife was damn I I think I'm Gonna Make
Her heady and I'll and I'll be you
probably yeah that would truly
get ready because the costume is hot
well it's Halloween it'll be much warmer
than your pantless number from yeah yes
exactly that was a little bit chilly uh
okay all right so Brandon did you know
that this crash character who's in the
very first episode was going to be
coming back well I we got an idea
because the the title of the episode I
think when we got it was originally like
crash's head or something like that and
then so we had an English so we had an
inkling but we were all very very
excited and then uh the guy Alex
boniello who plays them is so great so
we're pumped to have another our our
headless friend back on the show so both
your characters in the show have been
going through this transformation very
funny transformation had a year this
Gilded Age socialite uh yes who would
have a lot of thoughts about our
president currently being in Ireland you
have a hatred of the Irish well you'd
rather not speak of it yeah I think I
think Eddie should turn it actually
turned out an Irish woman I think that'd
be very funny it would be a funny twist
yeah but you both have been on this
journey right you're becoming a modern
woman uh what's it been like well Modern
Woman is having a sexual Awakening Gail
can say yeah right a radical sexual
Awakening it's very funny to me that
they they they took the you know the
most uptight woman and they gave her
this journey but that's what's so funny
it is fun it's fun to watch someone that
uptight unravel a bit and it's a voice
you give her to Rebecca oh I think I
mean it's a way that she speaks and
number one then the writing is so great
the writing is wonderful we're very did
you give her that voice the way that she
speaks and her lines are some of the
best she gets great lines yeah I you
know what I tend to approach characters
in this kind of Brandon loves to make
fun of me about talking about the
musicality
but it seemed very much on the page that
you know she has these long operatic
speeches and can change her mind in the
middle of a sentence and I'm wearing her
corset so I can only have so much breath
at a certain amount of time so it kind
of just the voice created itself but
it's a lot of fun to play right before
take show I'll you'll hear her
[Laughter]
why do you think that Hedy and Isaac are
such good friends on there I mean you
clearly are yeah in real life but what's
this Dynamic on the show well um I would
say it's the dynamic between the two
people who I think have the highest
status in the house and I think they
have the mutual respect for each other I
think Isaac likes to think he is the the
most Regal of everybody you know what
I'm saying uh but they think they have
the highest stats but they're actually
both buffoon they're both complete
buffoons and I think if you he were to
really examine it I think heady has
truly the highest status where like he's
always constantly like subconsciously
deferring to her and it always defers to
yeah exactly but Brandon is great
because you play this Revolutionary War
soldier who comes out as gay what is it
like for you to play a figure like that
in historical terms journey of
self-acceptance yeah back then yeah well
I think like so much of the political
discourse that we have in our country
right now is around what the founding
fathers wanted in this country to play
somebody from that era that sort of gets
to subvert it a little bit as that maybe
he was somebody that would deal with
something right now where like what they
were deciding back then wouldn't have
been the best for them so I think
there's something fun and subversive
about being able to play that character
it's been very cathartic in a lot of
ways too but when you guys first read
the script did you think this sounds
like a hit because when I first heard
the premise I go how in the world is
this going to work I remember yeah
fronts and going yeah yes
yeah did you like it right away oh right
away I yes right away I think I loved it
yeah I love movies like clue like those
like mad cap like sort of like screwball
comedies of people trapped in a house
and when you get this script and you see
that's exactly what it is you're like oh
my God one of the recurring jokes for
your character uh Isaac is his he keeps
hearing about how Alexander Hamilton and
the teacher becomes a huge deal a huge
deal can you believe it can you believe
he's on paper currency imagine your
rival whoever think of that person that
you have right now in your life and then
like 200 years in the future future they
are the most celebrated person
stands they're on the stamps they're on
the money such a unique joke I mean yeah
that's kind of what makes it so great
all right so we've had uh I think five
different cast members from ghosts uh on
uh I think I'm right here so uh we there
are some remaining though do you have
any uh recommendations on who should
come on next year because we've had Jay
we've had Sam we've had Trevor we've had
three is that all they're four and five
you're four and five I'll say how about
this I'd say Devin as thorfin you that's
a nice like jolt of energy in the
morning you're gonna love that he
definitely embodies the spirit of that
character Brandon you're a nice jolt of
energy
thank you I feel the same thing it's
great you are
um what about uh Alberta oh my God the
flowers we used to have everybody on the
show it's really we all really do love
one another and and they're all really
lovely naturally funny but you can all
get great story lines based on your
characters that's what I think is so fun
I'm just always Blown Away by the
writing because it's current but it's
also in the past oh yeah you still
figured out a way to merge the two in a
really brilliant way yeah yeah there
thank you very much and I truly
appreciate it and I hope it stays on
forever because I've got Halloween
costumes forever yes exactly there you
go you're going to play a revolutionary
gay soldier that comes out yes yeah
go for it coming soon
Brandon Scott Jones thank you very much
oh my gosh thank you very much bring us
together to watch the show it's so
beautiful and so funny you can watch
ghosts at 8 30 7 30 Central right here
on CBS and on Paramount Plus